- What I want to call this
chapter the one variable that
allows somebody to crush it.
Saba, mother fuckers,
I've been telling you.
- [Gary] (laughs) There he is.
Yo, how you doin'?
Life is good.
I'm in SF going to Uber's
headquarters and then
I'm flying to LA and
taking a redeye to Miami.
Okay, good alright.
So I'll see you,
I'll see you tomorrow.
I'll hit you up.
Have a good session.
Alright, bye.
These early days.
The early days of
building anything.
Oh, quick shout out to
everybody who left the comment.
Thank you for educating me.
It's the fourth wall, DRock.
It's not the third wall.
Fourth wall that I'm breaking.
Makes a lot more sense actually.
One, two, three, I got it now.
I was right, you
were wrong that.
You were right.
He was right, right?
- [Tyler] (inauble) Future--
- What?
- [Tyler] I was
listening to Future.
- Future, oh got it.
Oh, DRock, I don't know why
you're creeping up on my shit,
but, yeah, once in a while
I do really nondescript tweets.
I haven't done it
in a long time.
I'm gonna have to go
back to my 2009, '10, '11 stuff.
They're basically
once in a while.
Little things that I put out
that I want to recall seven
or eight years from now.
I think what I've been able
to understand through
the years is consumer behavior.
What people respond to,
what they care about.
I think I'm on the verge of
doing some interesting stuff in
a lot of different genres and
I think about it like
hacking culture.
Right, I think about you know,
you know what's emerging culture
and how do you infiltrate
it and bring it more value?
I use the word "hack"
as a positive. You know?
I think that a lot of the
Silicon Valley hack culture has
created some of the
greatest products in the world.
Whether it's an Uber,
a Facebook,
an airBnB, Google going back.
You know, so yeah.
I think I tweet stuff sometimes
that will be fun
to look back at.
And so, I think being in
Silicon Valley right now put me
in the mood of
that "hack" term
and yeah, that's it.
- [Tyler] Which one,
if any, do you want?
- What do you mean?
They're asking?
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
- Go up, the first
one and the third one.
- [Tyler and Gary] That one.
- And that one.
And the third one
if there's only one.
- Is that your kid?
- Yeah.
Naked singing.
(group laughter)
Look, a lot of things have
changed since
I wrote Crush It!
Mainly, the fact that when
I wrote it nobody knew what
the hell I was
really talking about
and now it's
established in our society
that, you know, if you are
the foremost expert in,
you know, "Alf" the TV show that
the social networks of the world
have become so big that
it's not just YouTube anymore.
That you've got all these
different platforms that allow
you to amass an audience
and you can make a living.
I mean the amount of people that
are making six figures a year on
Instagram is baffling to anybody
who's not looking
under the hood.
Influencer marketing is now a
foundation to our society and
that's a monetization strategy
that was very difficult to
comprehend for a lot
of people back before.
Just got some, you didn't
have to get out of the,
get in here, Ty.
(DRock chuckles)
Just got some
crappy business news.
Nothing bad, just good
old fashioned business.
But I was quiet
for like 17 minutes.
Totally changed the
vibes of our trip.
(DRock and Gary laugh)
I transform
into airport Gary.
Where did the, this
was always on me?
Okay.
This cool?
Steph, I'll tell you what's
really been obvious to me since
Crush It! which is 7 P.M.
to two in the morning
thing, it's everything.
When I tell you it's everything
like we're only
gonna be so pretty.
We're only to be so funny.
We're only gonna
be so charismatic.
We're only gonna be so
talented in what we do.
No question, the variable of
success in the last decade as
I became a poster child of
entrepreneurship and crushing it
and hustle, the people that have
outworked the other people have
succeeded at a
much higher variable.
And I'm sure we'll hear about
those stories when we profile
people that crushed it.
I basically want to say
something like from
October 7, 2009, I don't know
what date the book came out,
until today,
I have worked so hard,
so much more than I did
what I wrote Crush It!
and I've been documenting
it in my DailyVee vlog.
("Room 11" by Jack Tung)
The lack of patience that so
many people deployed against
Crush It! was the reason
so many people failed.
If you're reading this book and
you started something in
2010 'cause Crush It!
motivated you and you failed,
my belief is that
you didn't put in
enough work or you didn't do it
around your passion or you just
weren't talented enough but the
one that you can control the
most was your work ethic and
when I audited people through
the last decade
that hadn't succeeded,
they weren't working as
hard as it actually takes.
7 P.M. to 2 in the morning
is a real conversation.